they are the front line in what is a
very real war living up to three weeks
in the bush this is a tough job Ranger
Covenant checks on the cameras placed at
a poacher's entry hotspot
technology is playing a large role in
South Africa's anti-poaching fight
technology changed the way a lot and
then it's making our job easier
as we put in our cameras down to the
entry
[Music]
and then we detect the purchase way back
they were just walking in then it's
where you can hear the gunshot too late
too late they've already killed the
Rhino
around 40 kilometers away the field
teams check in with base camp
this is a private security company
operating on a few private reserves in
the software on the web portal they've
got a AI that works in and detects what
movement is picked up whether it's
animal movement if it is animal movement
is it a rhino is it an elephant is it a
lime so on whether it's human movement
and is there a vehicle
the latest technology not fully
operational yet this drone aside from
the data it collects we are told it is
also a powerful intimidation tool
it is much easier to cover large areas
from above Bush for as far as the eye
can see it
technology is increasingly
we spot a mother and her cough down
below
the day's heat is easing off poachers
often move at night we're told
and as the light Fades the patrols go on
and the technology changes
they use infrared to light up The Dark
Knight
even more light is given by the torch
but only the infrared can see this move
back to the naked eye nothing is there
if you see a poacher coming towards you
and you can point with this invisible
thought and he has no idea
South Africa has the world's largest
number of wild Rhino but it's also the
hardest hit by poachers there has been a
steady decline over the years Manpower
military-grade equipment and constantly
evolving technology still may not be
enough to save these incredible animals
from disappearing for good
Stephanie Decker Al Jazeera Limpopo
Province South Africa
head to here on